this video is brought to you by me I'm
in a t-shirt and a whole bunch of other
things you can buy them in the
description if you want k bye
so I have to write this script on my
birthday right but you know what I don't
even care this Ark was incredible and it
might very well be the best art
one-piece has okay look I know I say
that all the time you know I see the
comments people are showing me them
don't think I don't see them but let's
review the times I said that about
something I said it about the Barrett a
Ark which come on I think we can all
agree it's better than what came before
it
after that we have alabasta which was
better again Scotty PA was nuts water
seven set a new standard and now I'm in
Annie's Lobby it's not my fault it keeps
building like a snowball of goodness but
you know what Andy's Lobby it's not the
best but it is the best saga for sure
water seven was all set up and this is
just one long climax filled to bursting
with crazy stuff I have all sorts of
opinions on so help me blow up my
candles activate gear two and grab a
snack because I'm totally not Marc and
these are my first impressions of
thoughts on and review for a climax to
end all climaxes and the utterly
dumbfounding ridiculous explosion of
mystery and answers that came after this
is Annie's Lobby and it's aftermath
[Music]
[Applause]
this Ark was so incredibly fun and
stressful but mostly fun this was
probably the Ark I read through the
quickest which to me is indicative of
how ridiculously engaging and gripping
this section was it's not an
overstatement to say that I was
anticipating almost every single page
turn couple that with the fact that I
was left in an emotional heap and its
climax effectively this as I said in the
intro of very much is the climax to what
was effectively a whole buttload of
buildup taking cues from the last three
sagas and after that we get the roller
coaster of words that is the
affectionately and accurately titled
host Annie's Lobby and he broke my brain
in all sorts of ways so yeah look
forward to that basket of spiders
towards the back end of this video and I
used the word basket of spiders in the
most loving way possible
but before I get into the juicy nectar
of the post Annie's Lobby material let's
dive into the main dish first to explore
how and why it worked as effectively as
it did for me Annie's Lobby is
essentially an action-packed rescue
story sent it around the themes of
friendship loyalty and responsibility
and I love it but moreover to reiterate
again this in his Lobby
arc acts as one big girthy climax for
this water seven saga and one aspect
that I thought helped it feel breezy and
light was the number of characters
perspectives we get to see during this
infiltration at one point in the story
Luffy is doing his own thing the straw
hats are - we get the Frankie family's
perspective the shipwrights perspective
and even some really awesome character
stuff with cp9 and due to this arc
acting as a climax once again Oda as a
writer doesn't need to spend much time
establishing new characters if any
however that's not to say that there
aren't new characters introduced in this
arc either we get to meet the rest of
cp9 and in doing so establishes small
tensions between them which I honestly
really liked as we haven't gotten much
of a chance to see any flaring tensions
between them and usually when an author
shows us something it can be leveraged
later in the story to great effect and
shock horror
it was something I did notice that was
somewhat interesting was the
introduction of a power level set for
the cp9 ages on one hand I really like
this because it's a straightforward easy
to understand metric and pecking order
that tells us the viewer where the real
threats lie in this cp9 group - Luffy
and the others when and if they are
going to interact with these characters
which proves to be stupidly effective
later on it's easy to see here that Odin
knew and understood that the audience is
understanding of their dynamic was
important for what he had planned coming
up in the future but I'm curious if this
is how he would have wanted his idea to
play out in an ideal world from what
I've read so far in the story all it
generally prefers to establish who is
stronger than who by context clues
rather than straight out giving us a
list he's achieved this in the past as
the other organizations have had clear
leaders with rank subordinates and I
don't think any of us would really have
too much trouble ranking the straw hats
in terms of strength either or maybe
what who knows but this particular cp9
group was a unique situation so let's
accept the power double zipper mouth guy
for what he is a means to introduce the
audience to the pecking order of the cp9
agents it just so happens to be more
tell than in his show which is sort of
unlike one piece but if nothing else
this without a doubt identifies owners
awareness for how important it is to
manage an audience's expectations he let
us know their power rankings because it
will be very important later and aside
from that he establishes the hell out of
this world without delay as is the case
with pretty much any new place or island
we eventually reach we get gorgeous
establishing shots of the area as well
as maps some useful panels of the
massive circular waterfall that surround
this government facility - in the past
we've seen oda breakdown areas like our
long park alabasta and skype here all to
fantastic effect in combat he loves to
establish where all the fighting is
relative to each other and I love that
sort of attention to detail because once
again it adds tons of what I perceive to
be necessary depth to the world
everything is happening in real time the
struggle is visceral and we can feel it
all the more as a viewer or reader as a
result only this time there's one
significant difference it's on to the
context of a plan of action exposed to
us through the clever veil of the crew
establishing a strategy and what follows
this explanation of the plan
to rescue Robyn demonstrates to me Odin
knows how to pull off a fantastic
subversion that puts the viewer into the
mindset and shoes of its characters
check it out after going to great
lengths to make sure that we understood
the planet and that we understand the
area - instead of following the plan
like they were expecting he instead uses
the established characters to inform the
next move in other words he asks himself
what would Luffy do in this situation
[Music]
yeah that's about right when I saw this
I both panicked and laughed out loud
this is a stunning example of the
character in the story dictating how the
story is written and playing out have
you ever watched a show where you felt
like the characters were making
decisions are doing things they normally
wouldn't this was a particular point of
contention in Dragon Ball super as many
felt as though Goku was making decisions
and acting as though he was out of
character this creates a dissonance
between the story and the audience you
want your audience to go on the ride
with you not to scrutinize over every
decision you're making in it and so
often when I'm reading one piece do I
forget that this place isn't real and
that these characters don't actually
exist
rarely do I think then Oda what the hell
are you doing here because of its
characters and worlds one piece is one
of the most immersive experiences I've
ever had and this choice on Luffy's
behalf not only provides a nice
subversion to inject tension and
surprise into the current circumstances
but also offers great insight into Luffy
as a character deciding to without
hesitation to launch himself into quite
literally a small island surrounded by
something that's incredibly dangerous
for him what a whole mess of it all in
an effort to save someone who isn't
convinced that they want to be saved
when this arc began I knew it was going
to deal with a simple story of a rescue
mission get in retrieve the lost comrade
and booked it out of there
but it's the extra detail he adds that
makes this so thrilling to watch unravel
Oda is acutely aware of how the story
will make most of us feel as we read
through it so therefore when we are
expecting the crew to diligently execute
this plan as a solid unit we are taken
aback by the sudden dismissal of that by
Luffy however it doesn't bother us
because it's perfectly within his
character to do something like this and
in this
they matter he granted us reassurance in
the scene where all the characters were
making the plan in the blink of an eye
Oda catapults us out of her comfort zone
and plunging us into the battle
alongside Luffy experiencing the same
chaotic energy he's feeling achieving a
sense of connection to the character and
also a secondary goal for the crew to
work towards regroup with Luffy and that
is crucial and just to show my
appreciation for the action that Luffy
gets involved with here as he finds
himself surrounded by various Marines
time and again are both exhilarating to
watch but also hilarious demonstrating
to us the fun and aloofness of Luffy in
these situations and in doing so
unconsciously Oda is also making sure we
recognize the significant parts of this
area in person we need to have a
comprehensive understanding of how this
area is structured in order for a lot of
the story to make sense so Luffy doing
the rubber man hokey-pokey all over the
place looking for robbing is a
fantastically entertaining way to
communicate all of this information to
us without belaboring the point in
dialogue the staredown the first massive
moment that this arc fills - is this
iconic stare down of cp9 and i love it
for a host of reasons but a large part
of what made this moment so incredibly
effective for me was how it was set up
getting everyone here for this pose-off
wasn't an easy feat and took a
considerable amount of careful planning
on Oda's behalf to get here every single
character's abilities are used to
tremendous effect in this section and
really this whole arc and it doesn't
stop here but more to my point a leisure
writer wouldn't have made much of an
effort to incorporate all the secondary
shipwright and frankie family characters
in this initial blitz on the facility
when the crew made their first push
through the forces of Annie's Lobby it
was like storming the beaches of
Normandy enemies everywhere with the
only goal to keep pushing forward to get
into a position to help their allies but
what I admired about this sequence was
how every last character from the giant
animals to the shipwrights to the
Frankie family - even a couple of giants
that were befriended to their side they
were all used to tremendous effect in
pursuing this final effort heck even
kokoro gets involved during this section
somewhat which not only makes the
struggle to the top of this epic
staredown thrilling not only does it
make it feel more real but it also
grants believable
valuable utility to the characters that
supported their efforts they are not
just cheerleaders in this instance
without these secondary characters
there's a very real chance that they
wouldn't have made it in time to save
Robin so that takes care of how the
straw hats got there
how did Luffy get there
[Music]
food fuel sorry I just had to do the
Dublin accent there but yeah he has to
go through this guy who ranks relatively
well admits the cp9 posse and one thing
that I really want to say in response to
this scene in particular is that I very
much enjoy the fight scenes of one piece
I think they are really imaginative and
I adore the motivating factors that
color every decision a character makes
within them in this I specifically love
mechanically what this new gear 2 and
gear 3 system means for combat going
forward in Luffy's regard in Shonen I
love techniques like that that amplify
the users ability but come with a
built-in time limit or drawback for
using it the Kyle pan and dragon ball is
my favourite technique in all of fiction
which is no small feat considering there
are thousands of techniques in that
series alone and I love techniques like
this as much as I do because it makes
the setting of circumstances much more
suspenseful it's a gamble and it ties in
perfectly with the values of shounen
jump as a whole through tenacity to push
past your limits for the sake of others
it's great and I was absolutely
overjoyed when I saw it show up in this
particular battle however while I can
appreciate that this isn't important to
a lot of people one aspect I have
continuously praised this show for has
been its consistency in foreshadowing
every major event or beat that happens
in the story and I praise that because I
love the passion and consistency that is
engraved into this franchise one piece
is a series that rewards you time and
again for paying attention it's for that
very reason that goofs up and luffy's
falling out was as amazing as it was but
gear to luffy said he learned it off
screen and i guess that's fine or at
least that's what I thought before I
reread that scene and when I did
something stood out to me that added so
much color to the occasion it was this
quote from Luffy right before he began
fighting with gear 2 he says what I lost
the okichi I thought if I was going to
meet others just as strong out at sea I
had to grow stronger to protect my
friends even if I'm not that strong I
have friends I want to be with I've got
to be stronger than everyone or I'll
lose them I came up with a way to fight
a top strength so I won't have to lose
anyone so no one has to go away
for me this is the reason why the
introduction of this technique on a plot
level can be ignored or excused it might
have come out of nowhere in terms of
plot however it comes from a very
believable and emotionally rich place in
the character of Luffy on a thematic
level it's perfect the existence or
presence of these gear techniques are a
reflection of Luffy's internal struggles
as a captain the move exists because
he's scared they are physical
manifestations of his greatest fears he
achieves this so that no one has to go
away which begged me to ask what
happened to him as a child what he's
feeling here protection for his friends
is incredibly natural in this moment but
the wording feels like it's coming from
a specific memory or place in luffy's
mind and because of that I am more
interested than ever to learn more about
this fascinating little character and
woods Luffy disposes of this lesser
agent with relative ease all of the
independent battles each of the straw
hats were fighting come to a glorious
finish culminating on a phenomenal panel
presenting the entire crew standing
defiantly against the world's government
they're here for their friend and they
want her back Robyn's flashback the
flashback sequence that were presented
in this section is my favorite flashback
sequence out of all of the straw hats
that I've been presented personally and
I think out of all of them this
flashback might hit two more people on a
more personal level than the others due
to the subjects it's dealing with or at
least it did for me essentially this
flashback deals with the trauma misery
isolation and fear Robin has grown up
with kicking things off with Robin being
bullied and neglected as a young child
due to her powers and lack of a parental
figure present immediately right out the
gate we sympathize and get behind Nico
Robin and she floats from place to place
struggling to find a place where she
belongs that is until she gets to the
scholars of the island that are looking
into the missing 100 years of history
there we see Robin feel finally at ease
with someone who is genuinely friendly
to her we learn that she gets into
archaeology simply because it was a way
for her to bond or connect with other
people
actually she enjoys it but the goal of
this flashback is to hammer home the
notion to us that she wants to be
accepted and loved for who she is
begging to have some relationship with
anyone as her mother isn't even around
that is until she arrives to warn the
island of a massive buster call that's
been launched during this exchange I
learned a whole mess of fascinating
pieces of information one piece that
stood out to me primarily being the
obvious the government wants to stop and
squash the illegal investigation of the
missing 100 years and because of this
fear on behalf of the government it
becomes obvious that they themselves had
been bearing information that made them
look perhaps bad in the past or maybe
something even more sinister furthermore
there are some gorgeous and heartwarming
scenes in this flashback as Robin
finally gets to embrace her mother
before she's taken away from her again
never to see her again Robin then
flounders from town to town
surviving she needs to she deserves to
live and she's the only one left that
understands how to read the PATA glyphs
that very well might reveal the true
history of the world but over the next
20 years she gets beaten down by life
and horrible disgusting deplorable
people that use and abuse her and as the
flashback ends with her friends there
for her she realizes she isn't alone
that she finally has found a place where
she belongs and that she is allowed to
want to stay alive you know get you okay
revealed in a panel that made me weep
with joy as she declared
[Applause]
[Music]
what a phenomenal sequence and if I
didn't already want her to be rescued
now I do with a burning intense passion
in commemoration of my journey through
the high seas of one piece I figured
it's about time the TNM crew got their
very own official pirate flag design
made by the community for the community
this minimalist design is based on my
very own avatar with an obvious
one-piece twist I think it looks awesome
and it's available in t-shirts hoodies
critics sweaters phone covers and all
that good stuff all in the description
down below this design will only be
available while supplies last so if you
like the design or want to support the
channel cop yourself some new style and
join the pirate crew today Oh boohoo
if you can't pay the cash then you're
out with the trash and feel free to
quote me
[Music]
at this point in the tale after Robin
accepts that she wants to live the goal
remains to rescue her but now the gang
are given a secondary goal and reason to
split up into a bunch of different
groups Robin you see is coughed with AC
prism and thus cannot use her powers she
also feels incredibly weak and so as
Luffy rushes to her aid the rest of the
crew partake in intense combat against
the rest of the cp9 agents to find the
corresponding keys that match the cops
star in their possessions it's a super
simple concept but it's carried out in
this story masterfully and to great
effect let me explain you would expect
that as they split up the characters
would end up stumbling into by chance
opponents that best complement their
power set but in actuality they
encounter folks that both do and don't
making it feel all the more authentic
leading to the natural progression of
the various draw hat swapping and
exchanging opponents in the middle of
battle or finding themselves in serious
trouble what are the other highlighting
for me their respective character flaws
this was specifically evident with the
character of Sanji who was reprimanded
by Nami for this very reason but with a
hint that she might actually be growing
to like Sanji a bit more but maybe I'm
reading too much into that another
character for me that Shaun during the
section brighter that he ever has in the
past was chopper the added complexity to
his already established Rumble ball
mechanic allowing him to stockpile two
and three serving up more and more
severe consequences is an
extraordinarily compelling touch
similar to the gear system Luffy now has
chopper has the ability now to take
seriously dangerous chances and in this
case manifested in one of the most
awesome transformations I've ever seen
I didn't see it coming and holy hell was
it awesome I love everything about this
transformation and what it means for the
character it's haunting it's
intimidating and it's massively
meaningful and finally what I like
during this segment
besides the funny giraffe antics a noose
of livery acting as ouro sword was what
Sanji said to us up after Sanji the
hunter makes his daring last-minute
rescue he impresses upon Nami and who's
up the gravity of the situation that a
buster call has been made at the only
have so much time left and that they
need to all play to their strengths
looking goose up in the eye as he's
lying in agony to play to his strengths
and to quote read the situation and read
it he most certainly does the final
section this final section is thrilling
fun and intense and includes a fantastic
fight between Luffy and Lucci it's
everything a great fight needs to be but
it also happens in tandem with the most
compelling and anxiety-ridden moment I
might have experienced in my entire life
so there are seconds left right the
entire island is being destroyed the
same way Robyn's home was the director
of cp9 is dragging her to the gates for
delivery to the world's government which
on its own just has tons of symbolism
but we're not even close to done
everyone is hurting or out of position
as I mentioned earlier Luffy already has
his hands full with Lucci at this very
second and Frankie who was running to
save Robin gets halted in his tracks by
a tripmine nothing is going the team's
way it's looking as though Robin is
going to be captured and that the day is
lost when
[Music]
so ticking saves the damn day I left out
of my chair and ran around the house
totally took me by surprise
loose off in this arc has been used
better than perhaps any other character
and that's saying something because some
of these characters in this arc had been
used to genius effect he's the most
flawed and human out of all of the straw
hats and he's the absolute best underdog
that always pulls through in the end and
even after the climactic battle that was
luffy going through gear to a number of
times and even pulling out gear three
destroying the building itself after he
just barely manages to scrape a win
against Lucci luffy seems to be on
death's door he can't move and who
shouts down to him but boosts up
[Music]
what exceptional character growth and
storytelling with the arc itself ending
in what I believed to be the single most
exceptional and emotional sequence I
might have ever read through they jump
into the water listening to a voice that
was calling for them something familiar
but nothing they have ever heard before
and man let me tell you I was not ready
for what I was about to see the Mary I
personally found myself in an emotional
confusion at the end of the water seven
arc I found what happened with the ship
to be profound and intense character
rich and purposeful but there was
something hanging in the air for me that
I wasn't sure about and so I decided to
chat with some of my friends who knew
one piece better than I did I
specifically didn't discuss the spirit
of the Mary in much detail in my last
video as I wanted to wait and see how
the entire sequence regarding the ship
and its existence within the greater
story played out and on a plot level
I had a small issue with how this scene
at Frankie's place manifested when it
was revealed to us that there was some
mysterious repairman fixing the ship on
skype eeeh that begged the question to
me who is that this is a mystery in
fiction and in this instance this is the
story asking us to figure out who this
is however when it's revealed what is in
fact is I was sort of taken aback
because there was no way I could have
identified who or what that was with the
information available to me at the time
in the story which while I was reading
that scene in water 7 left me sort of
underwhelmed as I had been expecting
there to be some surge of insight for me
to get that aha moment that sudden
revelation that allows me to make sense
of everything that happened before and
on a plot level that's a perfectly fine
way to view or take it as a reader I'd
be lying if I was saying that I wasn't
at least a little surprised when I found
that there wasn't more behind the
identity of this person fixing the ship
the only instance in the story where
that spirit is brought up after the
moment in Skype here was during the
instance where Frankie was explaining it
I'm not including the instance in g8 as
that's not part of the story Oda wanted
to tell so in terms of plot because the
audience didn't have the tools to solve
the question posed by the story on a
plot level in that instance I felt a
little disappointed
however as the story continued and the
end hit its mark something else came to
my attention something that hit on a
much more emotional thematic and
profound level the Mary is much like the
rest of the crew a small little upstart
that's ill-equipped for the challenges
of the Grand Line it serves as a home
and a vessel for the crew admirably but
it wasn't really designed to leave the
East blue it is in a sense just like a
Saab trying its best but failing to keep
up and because of its reality the crew
now has no choice but to upgrade to a
new ship in order to adapt to the
upcoming challenges off the Grand Line
and beyond however and to US ops point
in the water seven arc it's still a
member of the crew and this whole saga
from the gambling in the Davie back face
to the out cagey altercation to the
fight between Lufia newstapa even the
confrontation in Enys lobby it's all
been about keeping the crew together in
particular it's been about Luffy's
growing awareness of how he needs to
constantly grow not only to fulfill his
ambition but to protect his crew from
the increasingly fierce and formidable
obstacles thrown their way and that
growth means that he needs to become
more adept at identifying unnecessary
risks and so he elects to get a new ship
when he's made aware that the Mary
cannot sail further this is of course in
keeping with his other larger more
prevalent leadership growth moments but
it also confirms Rousseff's biggest fear
that luffy will abandon crew mates that
are no longer useful to him since they
got the ship with us ops since it's a
gift from Kaia and since he's the one
who repairs it loose ops identity is
intertwined intrinsically with the merry
go he's insecure that Luffy will ditch
him when he loses all purpose just like
Mary did because unlike the rest of the
crew he's just a normal guy his dreams
are less ambitious and he's struggling
to keep up however with that said huzzah
pulls through a saga King proving
crucial at the in his Lobby encounter
without having to fight or take down an
agent at the end of the day he pulls
through so it's fitting that the
symbolic equivalent of USIP also pulled
through in the end one last hurrah of
being useful despite all the odds
despite common sense despite having no
setup it is the straw hats homes last
hurrah and its loss served to punctuate
that the grand
is dangerous and that luffy and co had
to step up their game in order to avoid
losing another member of their crew the
thematic significance of the merry in
this instance is obvious it literally
took every one of these characters away
from a trapped mundane life as an
outcast to one full of adventure
ambition and friendship it changed their
entire lives so on an emotional level it
makes sense to personify it and give it
impossible odds to overcome like Rocky
it's an underdog its success isn't on
the cards and yet it pulls through the
fact that it's unexpected is the point
of why it hits so emotionally in the
first place it's wire carries with its
so much meaning in the end and it's why
its final words hit so powerfully and
emotionally for me at the very end
absolutely destroying me emotionally
whether or not it's effective and
overcoming the plot contrivance --is is
subjective and I accept that of course
but I think in a shounen it's very
understandable that it went for
emotional resonance as that's what
people are going to remember when plot
details fade and the series progresses
into deeper and more fierce oceans of
the story the story of Enys Lobby is not
something for the faint of heart but it
is one I won't soon forget it's an
exceptionally well told tale of
friendship sacrifice loyalty and
tenacity but with a very human and
realistic message behind everything
bringing to life more than just a ship
but also the friends and family that we
have seen built over the last 400 plus
chapters and I can't wait to see what
they do next post
Annie's Lobby oh my god this arc was
absolutely insane like what okay so
let's go over some things but it's gonna
be impossible to cover everything we
learn a whole lot more about Luffy's
past in that it looks as though he may
have been raised by his grandfather who
happens to be a Vice Admiral in the Navy
which on its own is crazy but he also
comes flanked by Coby the very first
friend Luffy made after leaving his
village at the beginning of the story
and helmeppo from way back when he met
Xaro at the very beginning also and by
the way this progression that these two
guys share doesn't come out of nowhere
either as like the good one piece reader
I am
also pay attention to the front pages of
each chapter that at one point showed us
the story of how helmeppo and Kobe have
gone on various adventures together with
the Navy and would you look who's in the
picture with them it's monkey d garp the
grandfather of Luffy but we just didn't
know it at the time there's such an
absurd attention to detail in this
series and it's always purposeful which
is crazy to me and you know what else is
crazy
this is luffy's dad monkey d dragon
great name in addition to his grandpa
this is another person that has the will
of d and on top of that it also lends a
reason as to why he helped them back in
Lok Town I'm extremely interested to see
how this character of monkey D dragon
plays into the rest of the story as it
follows switching gears as expected
Frankie joins the crew but not before
showing us what he spent the two hundred
million fairies he stole on new
incredibly valuable wood and together
with the rest of the shipwrights and
Frankie family they build a stunning
ship called the Thousand Sunny and it
looks awesome naturally as I expected he
also comes along as the cruise ship
right and I'm delighted about that I
found him to be an exceptionally
engaging and fun character and the means
with which the crew have to coax him
into staying is both fitting for his
character and hilarious forcing him to
run around town without his speedos on
ohh also at the last hour Zorro
highlights to all of us why he's a
perfect number two to Luffy his
emotional maturity far exceeds most of
the crew and thus points out that loose
up is welcome to rejoin the crew but he
needs to flat-out
apologize without reservation and he
goes on to say that if you sub tries to
make up excuses they'll just have to
leave without him this I think is fair
but also tense for us as readers because
we just read through a sequence with a
sob running through various lines in his
head trying to slip back into the crew
without having to apologize again I feel
like a broken record here but the
writing and motivational factors in each
of these scenes with Zora do sup feels
so appropriate and real there's no fake
tension or drama everything just feels
natural and the way that this scene
plays out is almost extremely sad here
OSA begins naturally cycling through
lines as they sail away but no response
from Luffy or Zorro as they say they
can't hear him but as soon as Usopp says
sorry and accepts accountability for
what he had said and done beef
or luffy's arm stretches back leading to
the to embracing and dancing together
once again which fills me with all sorts
of joy and that's not all this freakin
maniac just keeps on throwing more and
more at you it seems everyone in the
crew gets a new bounty even chopper who
gets 50 berries but witness we get a
sequence of scenes wearing the people
the crew have left behind in their
respective villages and towns look at
these bounties remembering fondly the
friend that left them to follow their
dreams I'm not sure if this is a section
people get emotional during but I
definitely did it just serves the
highlight how far all of these friends
have come together but wait hold on a
second this I feel despite it being
played for laughs
might be I suspect indicative of
something something significant
regarding Sanji that I might not be
aware of yet I feel like this is acting
as foreshadowing in some way concern G
not be photographed this is drawn
specific attention to in the story and
so I wonder if it actually has utility
later hopefully we learn more about this
or maybe it is just a joke I don't know
I think it'll be kind of cool if he had
a power maybe it's why he seems to be
great at sneaking around but possibly
the single most interesting part of this
entire video subject matter for me came
in the closing chapters involving two
scenes and I'm sure you know the scenes
that I'm talking about one concerning
the discussion between shanks and white
beard and another concerning the
characters of Blackbeard and ace where
do I begin during the scene a bunch of
things come to our attention wow he's
big
wow he's sick wow global politics and
Wow's shanks has a weird power that saps
the energy out of everyone he walks past
what's going on there that's interesting
I want to know more I want to finish
this video so that I can keep reading
more shanks it seems has traveled all
the way to meet with white beard simply
because he wishes for ace to stop his
pursuit of black beard which white beard
flat out refuses to which seems like a
strange thing for shanks to request of
white beard until we learn some more
interesting information
the next scene I have no idea what
happened in this fight all I do know is
that Blackbeard is bloody scary and the
fact Luffy managed to dodge him when he
did before sky Pia was a miracle if ever
I did see one and perhaps shanks knew
that Blackbeard had this power and
wanted to save ace from going into
something he was unprepared for but I
want to speculate on something here for
a second this list of names port cast D
ace monkey D Luffy monkey D dragon
marshal D teach gol D Roger Jaguar D Sol
and monkey d garp some of these folks
are family but others aren't which means
it's not a family name they each possess
different abilities so it's got nothing
to do with the powers they share and
they are all at vastly different
strength levels they're also all
originally from different places as far
as I'm aware but I wonder if it has
anything to do with a crew that might
have existed at one point in time that
they are all maybe descendants of a
particular pirate crew that the will of
D is either a symbol for a particular
crew that once existed that some of
these folks were once part of or their
family was a part of in the distant past
or perhaps these are cursed people and D
is a cursed letter I don't know there's
honestly not enough information here for
me to go on just enough to rule out some
obvious ones like family or powers or at
least I think that's the case perhaps
the world of D was something that was
quite prominent in the missing 100 years
and we'll find out more as that unravels
perhaps maybe all I know for certain is
that I'm going to be saying that more
and more as the story unfolds before me
in the next 500 chapters and that's sort
of why I loved water 7 certain mechanics
and aspects were established as far back
as Barrett a with the Warlord's loke
time with monkey D Dragon which still
blows my mind and most definitely still
has a ton to unravel there and not to
mention the lead-up to alabasta in real
time these were placed by Oda years and
years and years in advance and the
patience and confidence it takes to
orchestrate your story in that sort of
super long-term fashion is not only
impressive but at least for me makes the
catharsis and payoff for these
subsequent storylines and character
interactions all the more potent on this
journey over the last two months over
the last 17
and over the last eight videos I've
managed to find not only this incredibly
engaging heartfelt story with the most
incredible characters but it's also
allowed me to interact with and become a
part of this wonderful online community
that you all have so graciously welcomed
me into and honestly I can think of no
greater thing to be so humbly thankful
for on my birthday we might be leaving
the water 7 Saga behind us but our
journey is far from over yet next week I
tackle thriller bark and I hope you'll
join me for that too as always I've been
totally not Marc I'll see you all next
week and sincerely thank you all so much
for watching
[Music]